et le colonel kadhafi au deuxième jour
de sa visite était donc reçu en fin de
matinée à l'hôtel de lassay la résidence
du président de l'assemblée nationale il
souhaitait s'exprimer dans l'hémicycle
cela lui a été refusé
une rencontre avec les députés a été
organisée mais ils sont nombreux à avoir
préféré la politique de la chaise vide
dans l'opposition comme à l'ump thierry
curtet patrice brugère olivier imbert
tambours trompettes et à pee wee
mouammar kadhafi passe en revue la garde
républicaine
elle salue sabre au clair en grand
apparat le leader libyen souhaitait être
reçue à l'assemblée nationale il n'aura
pas droit l'hémicycle devant les députés
mais tout de même à l'hôtel de lassay la
résidence privée du président de
l'assemblée
un entretien puis une rencontre avec
quelques parlementaires de la majorité
une roue coeur du symbole de la
démocratie française pour le colonel au
pouvoir depuis 1969
très musclé et que en même temps depuis
15 ans maintenant la libye a donné toute
une série de gages afin de revenir dans
le concert des nations je crois que
l'intérêt de la stabilité d'amis
teyrannaise c'est d'avoir une libye
ancré à nous intégrer plutôt que
plutôt que l' inverse mais de nombreuses
chaises sont restés vides ce matin la
visite divise jusque dans les rangs de
la majorité
je crois que cette réception et tout à
fait inopportune et et bien sûr je n'y
serai pas donc que le gouvernement
reçoivent les gouvernements reçoivent
avec tous les efforts qu'il a l'habitude
de faire
je peux comprendre ça mon enthousiasme
pas mais je comprends désormais puni
crossouard certes mais la phase de
kadhafi n'est pas à l'assemblée
nationale aucun député de l'opposition
n'a assisté à la réception question de
principe on est des rapports des détails
came to build et vous déroule le tapis
rouge alors que cet homme est un
dictateur c'est indécent moi je ne peux
pas oublier que le régime de kadhafi a
été accusée d'actes terroristes contre
un avion français
il y a eu des ressortissants français
qui sont morts
la trompe pro mission de kadhafi avec le
terrorisme devant les murs de
l'assemblée nationale ils n'étaient que
quelques uns manifestif le quartier
avait été bouclé
très tôt dans la matinée